Olá boa noite a todos é um prazer estar
com vocês novamente para mais uma live
vamos discutir aqui dois assuntos
inicialmente e partir paraas dúvidas de
vocês Bem primeiro artigo que eu queria
falar com vocês é sobre flora intestinal
sobre microbioma um artigo interessante
que chegou à conclusão era uma coisa já
muito suspeitada anos mas esse estudo é
mais inf fático foi feito em um ano
Então chegou-se à conclusão que o
microbioma flora intestinal pode afetar
a tomada de
decisões então inicialmente isso era
feito em animais
eh e agora nós vamos comentar sobre um
estudo feito em humanos uma uma equipe
de pesquisadores da escola de negócios
inid ou
INED que fica em fontan BL na França e
também do Instituto do Cérebro
e da Universidade bom da Alemanha então
é um estudo
multicêntrico buscou entender como é que
a composição do microbioma influencia as
habilidades sociais então para isso eles
recrutaram 101 homens
saudáveis então eles optaram por
escolher somente homens devido aos
fatores hormonais que poderiam complicar
Esse
estudo então Metade dos participantes
recebeu uma mistura de prebióticos com
próprio probióticos pre e pró Ou seja a
fibra que alimenta bactéria e as
bactérias né então entre as cepas tinha
lactobacilos bif do bacterium e a outra
metade dos outros 50 homens recebeu
Placebo ou seja pílula de farinha e o
tempo de estudo foi 7
semanas osição do microbioma desses dois
grupos foi analisada no início e no
final do
experimento então segundo os
pesquisadores
os participantes continuaram com a sua
dieta habitual e os prebióticos que são
as fibras permitiram que as bactérias
colonizem o intestino mais facilmente as
bactérias que foram dadas como
probiótico
certo então os participantes foram
convidados a participar de um teste
comportamental chamado jogo do Ultimato
antes e depois de receber a
suplementação e o princípio era alocar
uma soma de dinheiro a um jogador que
deveria então compartilhar ou não de
maneira justa esse dinheiro com o
segundo
jogador então o segundo jogador poderia
aceitar ou rejeitar a oferta
especialmente se considerada injusta
nesse caso nenhum jogador recebe
dinheiro que é chamado de punição
altruística então de fato o segundo
jogador sacrifica sua parte do dinheiro
para punir o primeiro jogador pela falta
de
generosidade esse jogo mentalmente a
sensibilidade à injustiça Então os
resultados do estudo mostraram que os
participantes que receberam suplementos
com pré e probióticos eram mais
propensos a rejeitar ofertas desiguais
ao final das sete
semanas mesmo quando os desequilíbrio
era leve enquanto que o grupo de farinha
o grupo Placebo se comportou de maneira
Idêntica durante as primeiras e segundas
sessões de teste e sugere que modificar
o microbioma tornou os participantes
Menos Racionais e mais humanos mais
sensíveis às considerações
sociais Então os cientistas também
observaram mudanças biológicas
participantes que no início do estudo
tinha maior desequilíbrio entre os dois
tipos de bactérias dominantes da flora
intestinal que nós chamamos de
firmicutes e bacteroidetes viram a sua
composição do microbioma evoluir mais
com suplementos Então teve um benefício
aí nessa composição com a suplementação
de pré
probióticos então esses indivíduos
mostraram a maior sensibilidade a
injustiça durante o jogo do
Ultimato então quanto maior er o
desequilíbrio melhor foi o efeito
do uso de pré probióticos e maior foi o
impacto aí no jogo de medidas de
sensibilidade a
injustiça Além disso os testes
sanguíneos antes e depois da
suplementação revelaram uma diminuição
nos níveis de tirosina que é um
aminoácido muito importante que é
precursor tanto da dopamina Quanto é
precursor
também da noradrenalina n e da
adrenalina então Houve essa diminuição
de tirosina no grupo suplementado após S
semanas de
suplementação a composição do microbioma
intestinal
eh segundo Esse estudo poderia
influenciar o comportamento social
através dos precursores da dopamina que
estão envolvidos mecanismos de
recompensa do cérebro isso segundo a
hipótese do grupo de pesquisa então
obviamente é um estudo Inicial e precisa
ser complementado com mais
pesquisas e analisando aqui as fraquezas
do estudo uma delas é que a amostra
consiste apenas de homens eles quiseram
fazer assim para simplificar mas futuros
estudos tem que analisar os dois
sexos Além disso focamos no que acontece
nos ní comportamental e biológico Mas
não sabemos porque isso ocorre no nível
psicológico observou um dos
pesquisadores o
plasma a singularidade desse estudo
reside no fato de ser o primeiro medira
influência do microbioma em humanos tá
porque os outros estudos que eu conheço
pelo menos são em
cobaia então para estudos futuros
podemos tentar entender essa reação
psicológica observada segundo um dos
pesquisadores Então como vocês sabem a
importância do do papel do microbioma
está sendo cada vez mais estudado
inclusive em transtornos psiquiátricos e
uma metanálise que foi publicada em 2021
no jornal Gemma
psychiatric mostrou que desequilíbrios
no microbioma podem ser encontrados em
pacientes que experimentaram depressão
ansiedade transtorno bipolar e
esquizofrenia e nós sabemos que a
dificuldade do momento é que não se sabe
se essa mudança no microbioma que causou
os problemas psiquiátricos ou se foi
vice-versa é o problema do ovo e da
galinha certo então esse é o primeiro
estudo mostrando que de fato as
bactérias do intestino podem ter um
impacto nas tomadas de decisões de Nós
seres
humanos o segundo estudo é um estudo
controlado randomizado que durou 6 meses
com adultos de idade mais
avançada e foi para ver a questão da
redução do
tempo
sentado perdão para para verificar a
questão da redução da pressão arterial
em relação a o tempo que você fica
sentado ou em pé então Foi verificado
que a redução do tempo sentado ou seja
ficar mais ativo mais em pé se você
ficar em pé mais 30 minutos por dia vai
reduzir a pressão arterial
sistólica em 3 mm de mercúrio então só
de você ficar um pouquinho mais ativo
coisa pouca durante o dia já faz
diferença então o objetivo desse estudo
foi verificar se uma intervenção
comportamental simples queer ficar em pé
diminuir o tempo sentado poderia
diminuir a pressão arterial e o grupo
estudado foi 283 adultos com idade de
média de 70 anos ão eram idosos e 1/3
eram homens e 2/3 eram mulheres com
índice massa corporal aumentado médio de
35 Então nesse estudo controlado
randomizado que durou seis mês os
participantes foram designados por grupo
de controle e um grupo de intervenção
grupo controle ficaria mais tempo
sentada em relação ao grupo de
intervenção que ficaria mais tempo em
pé o os participantes do grupo de pé né
que ficaram em pé receberam um total de
10 sessões de coach de saúde o manual de
estudo monitor de fitness de pulso uma
mesa de pé e um relatório de feedback de
atividade física no início e após três
meses todos os participantes definiram
metas individualizadas para reduzir o
tempo sentado ficando mais tempo em pé
fazendo pausas frequentes e as metas
foram alcançadas através de lembretes
internos por exemplo notar rigidez
muscular lembretes externos que era por
exemplo alertas do monitor de fitness e
lembretes de Hábito por exemplo ficar de
pé durante atividades cotidianas Como lê
o jornal O grupo de controle também
recebeu um total de 10 sessões de coach
de saúde e o manual mas esse pessoal
aí as sessões foram focadas em tópicos
de Vida Saudável como alimentação e sono
não especificando a redução do tempo
sentado então de modo geral eles todos
foram orientados a ter bons hábitos só
que o grupo de controle ficou mais tempo
sentado e não foi orientado a levantar
mais a cadeira então todos os
participantes usaram o monitor de
fitness no pulso por 7 dias durante os
quais o tempo total diário sentado Foi
medido Então como já foi comentado os
participantes do grupo de intervenção
reduziu o seu tempo sentado diário em 32
minutos então ficaram 32 minutos a mais
em média em pé em comparação com o grupo
de controle e a pressão caiu 3 mm de
mercúrio mas exatamente 3,5 mm de
mercúrio no grupo que ficou em pé em
comparação com grupo de controle
enquanto que a pressão diastólica não
mudou o grupo de intervenção também
aumentou seu tempo em pé em 28 minutos
por dia reduziu o número de períodos
prolongados de sentar mais de 30 minutos
de cada vez em 0,6 períodos por dia em
comparação com de controle e também teve
os resultados secundários que foi medir
peso índice massa corporal e
circunferência da cintura mas nesse caso
não mudou em relação aos dois grupos
então ficar em pé um pouco mais por dia
cerca de meia hora não mudou esses
critérios de peso ou de circunferência
da
cintura Então veja que uma coisa simples
como ficar em pé mais tempo durante o
dia pode ter uma diferença na saúde
Então vamos colocar essa mudança em
contexto Vamos considerar como é que a
redução de quase 4 MM de mercúrio na
pressão arterial sistólica observada no
grupo de intervenção ao ficar mais tempo
em
pé compara com outras intervenções de
estilo de vida comumente investigadas né
revisões sistemáticas e metanálise de
estudos controlados randomizados
concluíram que o treinamento de
exercícios aeróbicos produz uma redução
média da pressão arterial de 4 MM de
mercúrio em adultos com e sem
hipertensão ou seja o exercício físico
aqui teve um resultado bem parecido
né e o treinamento de resistência que ou
seja de músculo de musculação reduz a
pressão arterial em 2 MM de mercúrio
então a combinação de exercícios
aeróbicos e de resistência também
reduziu por volta de 3 mm de mercúrio
que é estranho né como é que a
combinação reduziu menos do que
isoladamente a questão do
aeróbico uma meta análise mostrou que
exercícios aeróbicos exercícios de
resistência que S de força treinamento
combinado e treinamento intervalado de
alta
intensidade exercícios também
isométricos reduziram a pressão arterial
em 4 a 8 mm de mercúrio Então dependendo
do estudo vai ter menos ou mais redução
da pressão
arterial já outra tipo de intervenção
que é a dieta Dash que é a dietary
approach to stop hipertension que é uma
dieta americana específica para baixar
pressão arterial que promove o consumo
de fruta vegetal Laticínios né com baixo
te de gordura grãos integrais uma dieta
muito parecida com a mediterrânea também
aves peixes e
noves reduzindo a pressão arterial em 5
mm de mercúrio enquanto que a dieta
mediterrânea reduziu em 2 MM de mercúrio
a perda de peso de 5 kg por meio de
restrição calórica exercícios ou so
acomida
eh já é uma outra intervenção aqui leva
uma redução de 4 MM de mercúrio na
pressão arterial
sistólica cada 1 kg de perda de peso
está associado a uma redução de
aproximadamente 1 mm de mercúrio outra
estratégia muito frequente é a restrição
de sal uma meta análise indicou que a
redução modesta de sal a longo prazo
cerca de 4,4 gramas por dia estaria
associado a uma redução de 4 MM de
mercúrio na pressão arterial isso é o
sal desculpa o sal refinado sal
comum a restrição de sal parece ser mais
eficaz em adultos com hipertensão
resultando uma redução de 5 mm na
pressão arterial sistólica enquanto que
os adultos que têm pressão normal vão
ter somente uma redução de 2 MM de
mercúrio ao reduzir o sal e os
medicamentos né temos medicamentos de
primeira ginha os
antihipertensivos são os inibidores da
enzima conversora deang tensina né como
é o
caso aí
da por exemplo
da fugiu o nome agora da medicação daqui
a pouco eu falo bloqueadores dos
receptores de angiotensina
betabloqueadores bloqueadores dos canais
de cálcio diuréticos tiazídicos Esses
são os mais comuns e as suas combinações
reduzem a pressão material entre 8 a 20
MM de mercúrio a sistólica né quando
comparados a nenhum tratamento ao
Placebo em resumo reduzir o tempo
sentado parece ser tão eficaz quanto
qualquer outra intervenção de estilo de
vida essa que eu comentei atividade
física aeróbica de
força reduzir o sal perder peso tá então
é bem equiparada com essas outras
estratégias dado que ficar mais tempo em
pé e sentar-se menos é prevenção de
custo zero e não requer especiais na
dieta ou atividade física e a ideia
então É bem
interessante Então interessante que o
objetivo inicial do estudo era que os
participantes reduzissem o tempo sentado
em 2 horas por dia mas eles conseguiram
apenas 1/4 dessa redução e mesmo assim
teve efeito Então os autores notam que
as restrições impostas pelos bloqueios
aí da pandemia podem ter sido uma
barreira para reduzir o tempo sentado e
de fato tempo sedentário aumentou em
quase 2 horas por dia em todo mundo
durante a emergência de saúde pública
pois muitas pessoas foram amplamente
desconfinadas as suas casas então estudo
foi feita durante esse período então
isso pode ter
interferido é interessante notar que
apesar de sentar-se um pouco menos os
participantes não aumentaram a sua
Contagem diária de Passos veja bem olha
que interessante mesmo não aumentando
número de Passo teve efeito então então
é improvável que os benefícios de
redução da pressão arterial foram por
causa de mais atividade física no
entanto os participantes reduziram a
duração média de cada período sentado e
a quantidade de períodos prolongados de
sentar Que praticava a cada
dia então gente é muito importante vocês
não ficarem sentado o dia inteiro
sentar-se por longos períodos de tempo
pare ter efeitos únicos na
saúde está na posição sentada faz com
que os grandes vasos sanguíneos nas
pernas se dobrem causa padrões de fluxo
sanguíneo turbulento e acúmulo de sangue
nos membros inferiores outros efeitos
sentar-se de forma aguda e prolongada
resistência à insulina disfunção
endotelial que
é atrapalhar a função da camada interna
das artérias alterações na oxidação de
gorduras e carboidratos redução na
aptidão cardiorespiratória diminuição da
massa muscular e da força muscular
ganho de peso e gordura inflamação e
alteração dos lipídeos sanguíneos das
gorduras do sangue sentar-se de forma in
interrupta por 30 minutos a algumas
horas pode elevar a pressão arterial em
até 3 mm de mercúrio devido aos padrões
alterados de fluxo sanguíneo então estar
na posição de pé com as pernas esticadas
provavelmente Evita o acúmulo de sangue
padrões de fluxo sanguíneo turbulento e
aumento da pressão
arterial ainda mais eficaz do que ficar
em pé é interromper períodos prolongados
de sentar com atividade física de leve
moderada ou alta intensidade A cada 30 a
minutos então se você puder A cada 30 ou
60 minutos fazer uma leve
caminhada é melhor
ainda os benefícios de reduzir o tempo
sentado não se limitam à redução da
pressão arterial interromper períodos
prolongados sentar com pausas para ficar
em pé ou caminhar também melhor os
níveis de glicose de insulina pós efei
embora pausas para caminhar sejam mais
eficazes intervenções de longo prazo
projetados para reduzir o comportamento
sedentário interromper períodos
prolongados tentar também encontraram
melhorias no peso corporal
circunferência da cintura gordura
corporal glicose de jejum insulina
hemoglobina glicada e e
colesterol Então pessoal por isso que
dizem hoje em dia que o sentar-se o
ficar sentado é um novo cigarro né
talvez vocês já tenham escutado isso de
mim ou de outra
pessoa fiquem atentos em relação a
isso Beleza vamos para as
perguntas Boa noite Eliseu Denise Miriam
taquinha
e
Eliane bem deixa eu dividir com vocês
aqui a
tela das
perguntas deixa passar para cá esse
arquivo aqui um minutinho
só
pronto vamos dividir a
tela dessa vez eu vou mostrar todas as
perguntas juntas aqui tá para ficar mais
ágil então eu não vou ler o nome da
pessoa que fez a
pergunta bem a primeira
[Música]
pergunta pessoa Ah não desculpa eh minha
vitamina D está
290 como é que eu posso
suplementar tá dando para ver para ler
bem aí pessoal se tiver pequeno na tela
me avisem Tá mas eu vou experimentar
mais um pouquinho aqui
pronto eu não entendi ô se você está com
vitamina D 290 ou se é 29 se for 29 que
eu acho que é isso que você quis dizer
você pode estar tomando por volta de
2.000 unidades de vitamina D3 por dia
2.000 por dia já vai ajudar aumentar tua
vitamina D para 40 depois aí de algumas
semanas de uso tá bom e Desculpa eu não
sei o nome de quem tá
perguntando só se eu colocasse no
individual aqui deixa eu colocar no
individual tou deixando no individual
vou deixar no individual mesmo é Silvana
que perguntou isso tá então Silvana toma
2.000 unidades de vitamina D por dia ou
você pode tomar também
50.000 unidades por semana se você
quiser tá para poder subir essa vitamina
D aí se tomar 50.000 por semana vai dar
mais ou menos 7.000 por dia tá mas enfim
por um período de tempo
aí não muito longo é
tranquilo Maria Helena pessoa com anemia
hemolítica pode comer banana verde feita
biomassa Se você souber eu
agradeço minha irmã tem Essa anemia faz
tratamento pela
Unimed eu não vejo nenhuma
particularidade numa pessoa anemia
poítica não poder comer banana verde
orgânica
Ok a banana verde é rica em fibras
vitaminas e minerais ele é muito
interessante paraa saúde intestinal
ajuda a baixar o açúcar do
sangue então vamos falar dos prós e
contras de usar essa banana verde
orgânica o pró em fibras ajuda na saúde
intestinal contém vitaminas e minerais
como vitamina C ajuda na absorção de
Ferro ajuda na regulação dos níveos de
glicose no sangue tem antioxidantes que
podem reduzir o estresse oxidativo eh
possíveis efeitos contras né ou
contraindicações pode causar desconforto
abdominal gastrointestinal em algumas
pessoas por causa dos gases algumas
pessoas vão fermentar esses gases e
formar
gases fermentar essas fibras e formar
gase
usar a banana verde né a biomassa banana
verde não substitui uma dieta
equilibrada e algumas pessoas podem ter
diarreia com o uso desse artifício
aí vamos pra próxima
pergunta pera aí uma bobagem aqui
ah Maria
Qual substância no creme é boa para
passar nas mãos no inverno eu gostaria
de conhecer a substância que realmente
hidratam daí seria fácil escolher
produtos tem vários produtos você pode
utilizar tá por exemplo o ácio
hialurônico porque ele tem a propriedade
de atrair e reter a umidade na pele
então ele vai ter um efeito
anti-envelhecimento a glicerina tem
efeito também umectante vai ajudar a
manter hidratado a
é um hidratante muito utilizado também
na indústria de cosméticos ele suaviza a
pele áspera a manteiga de
carité rica também em gorduras saudáveis
nutre hidrata profundamente as ceramidas
que ajudam a restaurar a barreira
natural da pele o óleo de jojoba que é
um emoliente que hidrata sem deixar a
pele oleosa o Aloe Vera né que no caso é
o a babosa também tem propriedades
antiinflamatórias acalmar a pele O
pantenol que é um derivado da vitamina
B5
óleo de
amêndoas e lactato de amônio Ok então
você depois volta o vídeo assiste a
verão gravada desse vídeo para anotar
com calma todos esses agentes aí tá ao
escolher um creme verifi se ele contém
uma combinação desses ingredientes que
eu acabei de falar e opte por cremes
mais espessos porque eles tendem a
formar uma barreira protetora mais
eficaz contra o frio e evite fragrâncias
que pode dar irritação em algumas
pessoas bem próxima
pergunta Marilda tá Dá fila pode
substituir o do
[Música]
homo sim algumas circunstâncias Pode sim
substituir tá a tadalafil ela vai ter um
efeito menos intenso para dilatar
o colo da bexiga e facilitar a
mixão mas em algumas circunstâncias a
tadalafila poderia est substituindo
Ok E além disso D fila vai ter um efeito
interessante de melhorar a circulação
sanguínea no pênes e combater disfunção
erétil porém ela pode dar efeitos
colaterais como dor de cabeça dor
muscular ror facial é o mais comum lafa
é dor muscular
Então tem que ser analisado caso a caso
mas é possível sim ser feita essa
substituição Com acompanhamento do
médico só um detalhe se a dox azulina
estivesse sendo utilizada que é o
princípio do Duomo para ajudar na
pressão arterial a baixar a pressão a
substituição pode não ser apropriada ok
vamos paraa próxima
pergunta Marilda costumo usar o bebend
AOL na penúltima Live o senhor sugeriu o
bendazol qual a diferença a diferença
básica que o bendazol é de espectro mais
largo ele pega mais bicho tá Por quê o
mebendazol ele vai pegar lombriga que
carid diase vai pegar aeróbios que é
enterobíase vai pegar tricurioso e
ancilóstomo que é ancilostomíase já o
abendazol ele pega todos esses bichos
ainda pega giardia neuroc cercose e
datid então ele é mais
abrangente Outra vantagem do bendazol é
que você pode tomar uma dose única
diária enquanto que o bendazol tem que
tomar duas doses por dia e o tempo de
uso é mais prolongado também a absorção
também do bendazol é maior em relação a
mebendazol Ok e os efeitos colaterais
também são semelhantes que pode ser dor
abdominal nuse e vômito
tá então por isso que eu prefiro
bendazol Marilda o cloridrato de
desculpa
levamisol substitui alguns dos
vermífugos esse produto específico que
você tá comentando é mais eficaz contra
ascaridíase que é lumbriga e ancilóstomo
Ok ou seja o espectro dele é mais
eh limitado ainda que o mebendazol então
levamizol também é utilizado como
imunomodulador para aumentar o sistema
imune em pessoas
imunossuprimidas então ele ele é pouco
utiliz hoje em dia eu levar misol para
te falar a verdade
tá mas se você tiver certeza que
ascaridiase ou anc lóc ele pode ser uma
opção
sim mas eu geralmente prefiro endas
porque ele é muito mais amplo
espectro a evima para covid ou como
vermífugo é 6 MG para cada 30 kg de peso
como antiinflamatório qual seria a
dosagem isso daí não se sabe Marilda não
é padrão isso tá apesar da Dora o sequer
ter divulgado bastante que é
antiinflamatório anticâncer
antidiabético Nós não sabemos ainda
porque isso é muito recente não tem
estudos ainda usando
atina como antiinflamatório então eh
qualquer coisa que eu te falar aqui vai
ser chute
inclusive não tem nenhum estudo que eu
saiba que fale do uso da EV mectina para
tempos
prolongados então eu não usaria com essa
intenção no momento
Ok Maria Helena mulheres brasileiras
usam pomada de Dex pantenol no rosto
essas usadas para bebês isso causa algum
dano não não causa nenhum dano não as
mulheres usam isso daí Porque tem
vitamina B5 né ou a PR vitamina B5 é um
hidratante como eu já comentei acalma a
pele promove a
cicatrização ajuda tanto na hidratação
quanto na regeneração da
pele você tem que tomar cuidado que as
padas de bebês em algumas circunstâncias
podem causar obstrução dos poros e pode
deixar a pessoa pensa a ter acne né a
ter espinha no
rosto e as pomadas para bebê são
geralmente espessas e podem deixar um
resíduo oleoso na pele tá então tem que
ficar atento quanto a
isso tome cuidado com sensibilidade faça
sempre um teste na pele antes de
utilizar um produto de maneira mais
e extensiva né para evitar qualquer tipo
de
alérgica pessoas que têm propão acne tem
que tomar cuidado com as espumadas de
bebê como eu já
expliquei e também é interessante se for
possível fazer o teste em clima seco que
aí a possibilidade da problema é menor
tá por causa da questão aí da obstrução
de poro
vamos pra
próxima também a
Marilda zinco disputa absorção com cobre
e magnésio mesmo que estejam todos
quelados eh Então vai diminuir muito a
competição mas ela existe ainda em certo
grau sim tá quando você quela o zinco ou
magnésio ou cobre com aminoácido
geralmente o mecanis de absorção muda
porque aí tá ligado à absorção do
aminoácido em si não do mineral porém
existe ainda um pouquinho de competição
sim mesmo tomando quelado Então se puder
separar o zinco e o cobre tomar zinco de
manhã e cobre à noite é melhor tá a
competição entre o zinco e magnésio é
menos
significativa então você pode ficar mais
tranquilo em relação a essa situação aí
então tente tomar o Zin de manhã um
cobre à noite ou vice-versa e pode
associar o quelado com magnésio
quelado o
próximo quais os benefícios que o senhor
vê nesse modulador hormonal hormona tá
já vi bastante gente utilizando esse
hormona ele é um composto que mistura
vários
fitoterápicos o geranil geraniol que eu
gosto muito Delta tocotrienol
daí genisteína ácido gálico e c3g
aí ele tem extratos aí de Urucum que é
esse bxa orelana do Red Clover n do aaí
que é o
etp essaa
dúbia então o Geran geraniol ajuda na
saúde ó na saúde cardiovascular tem
efeitos antienvelhecimento
ele pode ajudar também a aumentar a
produção de
testosterona o delta tocotrienol tem
efeito antiinflamatório
antioxidante melhora o colesterol e tem
propriedades anticancerígenas a
daidzeína e genisteína São dois
fitoestrógenos que atuam como
moduladores seletivos do septor de
estrogênio ajuda a equilibrar
hormonais pode ajudar a aliviar os
sintomas da pausa e promover a saúde
óssea e esse T de c3g é a cianidina TR
glicosídeo é um potente antioxidante que
tem frutas escuras como açaí e o
[Música]
camu Então pode ajudar a melhorar a
sensibilidade à insulina reduzir
inflamação e proteger contra danos
oxidativos e o ácido gálico também
antiinflamatório
anticancerígeno Então esse combinado aí
que
faz o hormona É bem interessante paraa
modulação hormonal para S de
cardiovascular e óssea além de ter
propriedades antioxidantes
antiinflamatórias tem um produto
interessante
[Música]
sim
Eliane Por que há tanta divergência
entre os médicos no uso de estatinas a
estatina estabiliza placa jeroma ou
somente diminui o colesterol faz as duas
coisas Eliane
só que existe 25 fatores de risco
importantes para a saúde cardiovascular
e o colesterol é somente uma delas
tá essa divergência é porque muitos
médicos vão ter um viés pro
lado positivo da estatina porque foram
totalmente aí catequizados pela
Indústria Farmacêutica e vão ignorar os
efeitos colaterais ão basicamente dores
musculares fraqueza
aumentam no risco de diabetes tipo do e
problemas no fígado e vai ter médico que
vai ter um viés pro lado negativo porque
vai ficar muito preocupado com os
efeitos colaterais e não vai valorizar
tanto o efeito das
estatinas entendeu então essa que A
grande
questão que que eu faço hoje em dia
Eliane eu uso doses baixas de estatina
associado a outros elementos então
quando eu faço isso eu nunca me
arrependo eu tenho sempre os efeitos que
eu quero reduzo praticamente a zero os
efeitos colaterais e ainda dou
benefícios adicionais ao paciente
tá então não é necessário ter essa
guerra tão
ferrenha entre os que defendem e os que
não defendem a estatina o caminho do
Meio aí como nos ensinou Buda é o
melhor Hã agora não precisava nem dizer
que essa pergunta era do Eliseu
né Eliseu acho que eu sou especialista
no Michael Jackson vamos lá na autópsia
do corpo de Michael Jackson constataram
que ele realmente tinha Vitiligo quando
ele era vivo fez tratamento à base de
hidroquinona para multiplicar o vitiligo
não A hidroquinona não multiplica o
vitiligo o que ele faz é deixar a pele
mais
clara ele agiu certo
Olha eu acho que não tá ele fez o qu Em
vez dele tentar ficar preto ele quis ou
seja Em vez dele tentar bloquear o
efeito do Vitiligo ele fez o contrário
né
Eh eu te digo que é complicado
você criticar uma situação dessa aí mas
eu não teria feito Dessa forma não eu
teria teria tentado tratar o
vitiligo Michael Jackson tinha
osteoartrite isso tem alguma coisa a ver
com multiplicação do Vitiligo sim quem
tem uma doença autoimune geralmente tem
risco comentado para ter uma segunda
doença autoimune Vitiligo é doença
autoimune e talvez essa osteoartrite
dele fosse artrite hematóide não sei de
detalhes Mas se for Artrite reumatoide
tem a ver
sim médico do Michael Jackson aplicava
um anestésico propofol embaixo do joelho
do cantor para não deixar
marcas não entendi injeção de de propal
deixa marcas qualquer injeção que você
fizer ô elizu se for repetido vai ficar
marca tá por isso que os drogados tentam
esconder as marcas de injeção injetando
em lugares estranhos certo o médico do
Michael Jackson recebia 50.000 por mês
para fazer o seguinte aplicar propofol
para ele dormir continuar dentro do
quarto do Michael
Jackson a noite toda para acompanhar o
sono ao amanhecer aplicar uma injeção eh
para AL acordar caso contrário não
acordaria se o Michael Jackson
contratasse o Dr Alan qual seria o
tratamento para ele dormir e acordar
nada disso né meu amigo Você deve estar
brincando comigo
né Você sabe que meu negócio é outro
nunca é dar propofol para para ninguém
né que são maluquice um negócio
desse né logicamente Você conhece o que
eu uso pro sono né é o gerenciamento do
sono ritual do Sono Tom ambiente escuro
tranquilo temperatura
adequada poderia poderia estar
utilizando fitoterapia técnica de
relaxamento meditação Mas nada de usar
propofol
né na Live sexta-feira da semana passada
você confirmou que a absorção de
vitaminas hidrossolúveis são
prejudicadas a serem ingeridas com água
contendo sal rosa Himalaia se a água não
tiver sal porém tiver limão absorção de
vitaminas hidrossolúveis também
prejudicado não não vai acidificar o
ambiente vai ajudar na absorção da
maioria das vitaminas D solúveis no caso
suplementos F solúveis eu acho que não
tem
problema porque como a gordura garante
que o suplemento será absorvido então o
sal rosa e o limão não irão atrapalhar
absorção
confere sim não tem nada a ver não vai
interferir mesmo não
certo
então o sal rosa ele pode alterar o
pegar do estômago e e afetar a absorção
de algumas vitaminas hidrossolúveis
porém a limão vai melhorar a absorção de
vitamina
C Ok e também vai aumentar a absorção de
Ferro
[Música]
Eliseu se aquela mulher estivesse
tomando probiótico D3 ela teria matar
aquela bactéria sem perder mãos e pés
que mulher você tá falando Eliseu
não sei que mulher é
essa vou pular essa pergunta tá porque
não sei de quem você tá
[Música]
falando Maria Helena
Eh por favor você sabe as verdadeiras
vitaminas que tem no mocotó
puro somente com parte do
[Música]
boi
bem vamos lá
você quer saber das vitaminas Eu imagino
que você deve est querendo saber dos
nutrientes né em termos de vitamina você
tem vitaminas do complexo B B2 B3 B6 B12
tem vitamina A também agora tem vários
minerais também vai ter cálcio vai ter
magnésio fósforo zinco ferro e vai ter
bastante proteína casa do colágeno né o
principal dos aminoácido glicina prolina
e
hidroxiprolina certo então o mocotó é
muito bom paraa saúde
intestinal é muito bom paraa saúde das
articulações para fortalecer ossos
melhorar o sistema imune por causa da
glicina né Por causa também dos outros
aminoácidos e na recuperação muscular tá
na Live da semana passada você confirmou
que ação de vitam do solvis
Ah não que eu já respondi pera
aí na Live da semana passada você leu um
artigo que recomendou se expor durante
10 minutos a luz solar primeiros 40
minutos após acordar para ativar o ciclo
cardiano mesmo que esteja dublado antes
da pessoa ir para o quintal se expor a
luz solar ela passou pelo corredor e foi
obrigada a se expor à luz da lâmpada Eu
já respondi isso elizel não tem problema
nenhum ainda assim ela consegue ativar o
ciclo cicano consegue ao dormir às 21
horas e acordar 5 da manhã acontece que
nos primeiros 40 minutos a partir das 5
horas ainda é noite aqui no Rio de
Janeiro Isso significa que eu fico
impossibilidade impossibilitado de
ativar o ciclo cadian nesse período de
40 minutos após acordar não não fica
impossibilitado a exposição a luz solar
é recomendada para ajudar a regular o
ciclo circadiano Porque a luz natural é
rica em espectos de luz
azul que são mais eficazes em sinalizar
o cérebro que é dia ão ajudando a
ajustar o relógio biológico então passar
por um corredor com luz artificial antes
de expor a luz solar não vai impedir
nada ativação do ciclo
Cardano e mesmo em dias nublados a luz
solar natural é mais intensa e eficaz na
ativação do ciclo cadian do que a luz
artificial
típica Tá então não tem nada a ver se
você foi exposto a luz artificial antes
da luz natural não vai desbloquear nada
isso aí
se você acordar antes do amanhecer e a
luz solar ainda não tá disponível nos
primeiros 40 minutos eh eu não me
preocuparia muito com isso mas uma
alternativa é você utilizar uma lâmpada
de luz branca lâmpada de luz branca
brilhante ou uma caixa de luz light Box
que emita luz azul em casa para simular
luz solar e ajudar a ativar o ciclo c
cardiano e assim que o sol nascer
procurasse Expor a luz solar direta o
mais ráp possível ok
com relação dejun tratamento de doenças
crônicas e correção de defeito de DNA o
senhor acha que seria uma boa
alternativa no auxílio de tratamento de
doenças da adrenais como se fess adrenal
fadiga adrenal ou estresse gerado pelo
jejum causaria mais danos às adrenais do
que benefícios eu se a pessoa tiver com
a adrenal muito prejudicada Tiago é
melhor que el cuide disso antes de fazer
jejun intermitente
tá porque existe sim essa possibilidade
do impacto do jejum sobre a saúde das
adrenais Então os benefícios do jejum é
estimular autofagia que é a renovação
das células danificadas e também
Regeneração celular isso vai corrigir
defeitos de DNA vai reduzir inflamação e
aumentar a sensibilidade a
insulina porém se a pessoa tiver muito
estressada o jejum pode ser um fator
adicional nesse estresse então é melhor
você cuidar primeiro dessa questão
adrenal antes de começar o
jejum Além disso as pessoas que têm
problemas aí de regulação da adrenal
podem ser mais propensas a Hipoglicemia
o jejum pode aumentar esse risco
tá então é melhor você cuidar primeiro
da insuficiência ou da do
hipocortisolismo antes de fazer jejun
intermitente
Ok ah o ciclismo é melhor do que corrida
pode fazer eh ciclismo todos os
dias Qual é o sol comum que você citou
na
Live sol refinado só Branco refinado né
É isso que eu tô querendo
comentar bem o ciclismo tem uma vantagem
que tem menor Impacto nas articulações
do que você fazer a corrida eu mesmo
tive problema com corrida de ficar com
Face de plantar Então essa é uma
vantagem muito grande do ciclismo
e também existe aí uma um trabalho
diferente nos músculos das pernas né em
relação ao
ciclismo vai trabalhar de uma maneira
diferente quadr os is tibiais os glúteos
e as
panturrilhas e também tem a questão da
variedade que você pode ter né Você pode
tanto fazer ciclismo de estrada ou
ciclismo de mountain bike né então tem
essa esse lado aí mais aí lúdico
também e agora a vantagem da corrida
seria mais fortalecimento ósseo porque o
que é o lado negativo da corrida também
por outro lado é o lado positivo porque
esse Impacto que pode causar danos né
também pode ser positivo para aumentar a
desidade óssea e fortalecer os
ossos a grande vantagem também ao meu
ver é a simplicidade não ex exindo muito
equipamento né Você sabe que tenho aí
umas bicicletas
caríssimas Antônio
Renato correr todo dia você diz que não
é muito saudável tem que dar descanso ao
sim
é você pode alternar eu falei isso na
semana passada pode alternar entre
caminhar e correr né Eh o seria o mais
adequado caminha um dia outro dia você
corre leve outro dia Você caminha de
novo outro dia você corre mais mais
pesado mais puxado o importante é evitar
lesões an
Ok qual é o mínimo para saber no
aparelho se estou na dieta
cetogênica eh a faixa de cetose leve
Antônio é entre
0,5 a 4 de Beta hidrox butirato tá entre
0,5 a 4 no aparelinho que mede Beta
hidróxi putir
eh qual a diferença na dieta cetogênica
normal e cetogênica
terapêutica Não vejo diferença nenhuma o
só objetivo que é diferente tá
cetogênico cetogênico né vai formar uma
cões do sangue eu não sei se eu entendi
totalmente essa pergunta sua
e que eu fazer para evitar um infarto ou
AVC a curto prazo a curtíssimo prazo é
tomar Aspirina tomar o as tá agora isso
daí é uma emergência tá o que vai
realmente ser muito beneficial para você
é a dieta atividade física o sono
adequado é o gerenciamento do Sono se
você fuma parar de
fumar cuidado com álcool se você bebe de
maisis beber menos né todas essas coisas
aí que são importantes Tá mas numa
situação de emergência a Aspirina OAS de
100 mg por dia entre 70 80 entre 70 e
100 mg por dia pode ser uma medida de
curto prazo aí de emergência ok
Antônio o ciclismo tem mesmo efeito de
uma corrida de alta intensidade uai
depende do tempo que você fizer o
ciclismo e depende da intensidade né
certo é a mesma coisa você me perguntar
aqui
eh levantar 10 kg de peso é igual a
levantar 100 kg de peso não é o ciclismo
pode ser feito de várias maneiras
diferentes
né então é não dá para fazer essa
comparação do jeo você tá perguntando
[Música]
não como eu já falei a diferença
principal entre ciclismo e corrida é o
tipo de músculo que vai ser
atingido
é porque a Cora de alta intensidade vai
trabalhar diferente do que o ciclismo
porque ele pega mais a musculatura né do
tronco do core e o ciclismo vai eh ter
mais Impacto mais intenso no quadríceps
glúteos e es tibiais né e menos na na
panturrilha por exemplo e a cuida de
alta intensidade de modo geral queima
mais caloria do que o
ciclismo de modo geral obviamente
né só que o ciclismo vai ser mais
beneficial né
para pessoas que T problemas de
articulações
bem vamos
lá ele eu não sei de que vídeo você tá
falando tá eu tenho mais de 1 vídeos já
então aquele vídeo fica complicado para
saber do que você tá falando
aqui não não é esse o fato tem que ver
as característica do azeite tá grau de
acidez se ele extra virgem né a
quantidade de polifenois que ele tem
isso é muito mais importante se ele
amargo ou
não a Glutamina é importante
principalmente pra saúde intestinal
Eliseu e para evitar de gripar eu quando
eu faço atividade física muito intensa
Geralmente eu
gripo então a Glutamina me evita de
gripar é o principal
efeito da glutamina para mim tá E além
dela ajudar no sistema imune ela ajuda
na saúde
intestinal tem estudos que sugerem isso
sim que a radiação eletromagnética baixa
a quantidade de espermatozóides
pepsina
Genciana não sei o que é
Eliseu não sei o que
é vou chear isso
[Música]
tá Aparentemente refere-se a raiz de uma
planta conhecida como
[Música]
Genciana que é uma dessas bitters né que
dessas plantas amargas que ajudam na
saúde do
do fígado e ajuda também a melhorar a
digestão Então deve ser isso tá então
essa agana na verdade é é um plus que
colocou nesse produto para ter um efeito
adicional aí alidade betaína
então esse tal farmacutico é muito
utilizado para encher as cápsulas por
dentro são os excipientes
tá E ele normalmente é ele não causa
nenhuma reação no
[Música]
organismo é uma alternativa Eliseu Mas
eu não faria assim eu faria 12 14 horas
por dia em vez de fazer um jejum longo
desse uma vez por
[Música]
semana a macadamia da Natura você também
aprova não conheço bem mas se for
macadâmia é natural né então é
interessante sim
fiz uma pergunta no formulário Eu já li
essa pergunta né ô
Antônio não é a última pergunta aqui ó o
ciclismo tem mesmo efeito de uma corrida
de alta intensidade Não é
esse quem tá assistindo ao vivo
pessoal pera aí será que você tá falando
de uma outra pergunta ah atualizou aqui
tá
verdade diferença de valor na dieta
cetogênica normal e terapêutica no
aparelho novamente o eu não tô
entendendo o que você quer dizer com
essa diferença
aí eu não tô entendendo de onde você tá
tirando essa esses termos aí cetogênica
normal e terapêutica os valores eu falei
para você entre 05 e quatro se você quer
ser mais rigoroso ainda entre um e
quatro entendeu
tá então se você quer ter um um uma
certeza maior ainda dos benefícios
terapêuticos da dieta cetogênica para
desinflamar e tudo mantém entre um e
quatro no aparelho que medde o Beta
hidrox butirato Tá bom então Eliseu tá
ao vivo Antônio
Renato e a Tami quinha né e três pessoas
ao vivo só eu tô com moral baixo hein
tá muito chato as minhas lives né
ah Estamos quase 1 hora de Live pessoal
já respondi bastante pergunta Tem mais
alguma V vou vou responder mais duas
perguntas e vamos encerrar aqui
né Tem mais
perguntas as duas perguntas que eu fiz e
que você não entendeu foi porque hoje à
tarde postei vídeo lá no grupo é eu não
tô acompanhando o grupo Eliseu eu não
consigo Você me desculpa tá de vez em
quando eu entro lá mas eu não não me
coloco essa obrigação de acompanhar o
grupo não tá o grupo é mais para vocês
interagirem entre vocês a interação
comigo é nas lives semanais Ok A miram
tá ao vivo a it também
tá água com limão pode impedir infarto a
curto
prazo a curtíssimo prazo eu que não vai
fazer diferença não Antônio Renato agora
Médio prazo longo prazo sim vai fazer
diferença deixa eu ver aqui
se Que vídeo é esse que tá falando
Eliseu
é deve tá mais para trás esse vídeo não
sei Que vídeo é esse
não pessoal vamos evitar de sabe de
fazer referência à coisas do grupo tá
aqui no nas lives tá
porque o grupo é mais para vocês
interagir entre vocês de vez em quando
eu vou lá mas eh o objetivo da Live
semanal é tirar as dúvidas tá
Ah tem um negócio aqui do Gabriel azine
aqui que ele tá afirmou que no
YouTube que uma vez por mês ele aplica
em si mesmo injeção de 1 Milhão Mil
unidades de3 seria duas injeções de
600.000 sem ter nenhuma doença autoimune
assim ele não precisa consumir D3 via
suplemento eu já fiz isso na pandemia
Tomei duas injeções de 600.000 de uma
vez só para mim aumentou bem pouco a
vitamina del bem pouco aumentou sei lá
15 unidades tá porque na verdade apesar
da ser uma dose alta não é absor tudo
uma vez fica no tecido gorduroso tá
eh para todo mundo eu não recomendaria
isso daí mas para boa parte das pessoas
isso aí pode funcionar
Sim foi esse que eu encontrei aqui no
grupo esse material do Gabriel azine
aqui agora você tá falando de
testosterona Não
sei não sei
não batendo o olho aqui não não tô vendo
n testosterona
não você Dev tá falando do do vídeo do o
Diogo deja
né
ah eu não vou ver esse vídeo agora
Eliseu tá pode ser que eu veja depois
mas por favor não façam essa essa
dobradinha entre grupo e pergunta não tá
se vocês querem que eu responda as
perguntas façam a pergunta no no
questionário ou ao
vivo nanos rouas nas vacinas procede
Ah não deveria ter falado Essa palavra
não eu eu acho muito Improvável viu
Antônio Renato eh não posso confirmar
essa informação
não
certo esse vídeo é curto vamos ver aqui
tá eu não vou assistir esse vídeo todo
não tá isso que ele tá falando aqui eu
já falei anos atrás O Eliseu tá isso
aqui não é nenhuma novidade não tá agora
o o seguinte tem estudo que fala que a
testosterona aumenta risco de doença
coronariana e tem outros estudos que
fala que diminui o risco então é muito
controverso na literatura e eu acredito
que os estudos que falam que a
testosterona pode piorar a saúde
arterial coronariana é por conta de
pessoas que TM hábitos saudáveis ruins
aliás hábitos saudáveis ruins hábitos de
vida ruins tá pessoas que estão acima do
peso pessoas que não fazem atividade
física pessoas Estão inflamadas e
oxidadas tá então a testosterona só vai
funcionar bem para prevenir as doenças
como esse médico tá falando em pessoas
saudáveis não inflamadas Ok Então cuide
primeiro da inflamação cuide primeiro da
oxidação cuide primeiro dos bons hábitos
para depois pensar em repor testosterona
porque senão a testosterona vai dar um
backfire aí vai sair o tiro pela culatra
certo então essa esse vídeo aí não é
nenhuma novidade eu já falei desse
assunto Anos Atrás só que não é assim
também não tá É não é dando sair dando
testosteron para todo mundo e achar que
vai dar certo não funciona assim
primeiro ter que desinflamar a pessoa eh
cuidar dos hábitos de vida para depois
entrar com testosterona porque a
testosterona pode piorar o metabolismo
em pessoas inflamadas Ok bem pessoal é
isso então um abraço para vocês até a
semana que vem
Obrigado TAM miquinha